доброго дня мене золоті наталі сара
жіночою читали інформатик про дільничні
класах автор підручнику інформаційна
культура
інформатика сертифікати в 4 google дала
сни до спини ти мовчки і масячи з google за
педагогічно спина нота d ми говоримо про
ітані та і ктт педагогічним приємний
досвід місця початковий матеріал це
державних мемов до-ре-мі зонального світло
нею підготовкою вченню програма
інформатика ловити нові формулювання
з передачі ним ще dt нас може
практично викинуто єдино стаціонарному
портативному буде комусь мобільному
прибудова незалежна вітри заманити його
партійних систем та на закладену крученого
в інста льова не програмі на
персональному комп'ютері буду його ікону
вати завдання че в інтернеті досвід
практичним частим про нова але таким
чином
ще можна не за монтажу, а ти ж одну
програму на стаціонарний комп'ютер
кремах противні системи а викону від
особи в інтернеті змін ще вигляд був і сів
програмі інформатика качанів і школі з
дітьми лісу через новий бочче не важливі
steam їмо на це інформаційної
грамотності дитину з комори
успішності
замовчування інших предметів для петренко і
вимкнення початкових предметів було до
до ночі танін електронний у тексті
робота з електронними картками that for a
мої майстерності графічними даними та
вигляди схем та діаграм у зірок густі
mcedit і нали шепочеться читати щось з
примати текст з екрану мета досягти
важливо з комори до-т компетентності
було віддано дізнаємось на неї сарида речам і
для харчування текстів у темі текст робота
з карткою заплановано пекти свч немає м &
графіка
так перед бача я в міні orient уват із за
допомогою карт на приклад через це не
покрокового захід у знову і населеного
пункту свого видного до
а в четвертому класі вручення моторики
талакани
сонячні системи звузили iv
азіз схемам та
то діаграм і подано акцентом на
меню бренд вата в даному графічному
зображенні та пам'ятаю ось і в тому ж готовому
схеми пробач дати аче діаграми
перед варівати тексту це числове
графічну інформацію виглядає
діаграм знати про нього в читаному шаблоні
с та графічних покинутий